c'est d'être en direct avec nous alors
vous en pensez quoi de cette rencontre
tirana scaglia avec des dirigeants
européens mais je pense que c'est une
rencontre à la fois nécessaire mais
délicate à la fois délicate pour les
européens pour les 27 pays membres de
l'union européenne qui doivent trouver
une position assez claire
mais une position qui doit ménager le
principal acteur celui qu'on attend avec
impatience qui est moscou qui est la
russie parce que c'est la russie qui
dans cette affaire sera véritablement en
mesure d'arbitrer la suite des
événements donc cela na kika de sky à
qui est actuellement à bruxelles va
essayer faire de faire valoir sa
position et bien sûr l'importance des
manifestations de ces derniers jours à
minsk en biélorussie
mais cela n'empêche pas effectivement
les 27 pays membres de trouver la bonne
mesure des sanctions il en faudra il
faudra des sanctions contre la
biélorussie tout le monde s'accorde sur
ce point mais quelle sanction est vite
et bien sûr les sanctions à caractère
économique qui pourrait pénaliser le
peuple russe mais privilégier les
sanctions à personnage c'est à dire des
sanctions qui touchent directement des
responsables du gouvernement de du
gouvernement de jeu luka chilcot donc
c'est ça l'importance mais il ya une
petite obstruction qui s'est glissée
entre temps dans ce dans cette démarche
c'est un petit peu une autre affaire qui
n'a rien à voir avec la biélorussie et
qui est le problème du conflit entre la
grèce et la turquie
parce que entre les vingt-sept et un des
membres chypre république de chypre qui
parti est particulièrement dur et
intransigeante en liant toutes sanctions
qui pourraient être décidées à
l'encontre de la biélorussie a
finalement une solution dans le conflit
qui oppose actuellement la grèce et la
turquie sur la présence des bateaux de
turc de deux forages en ce qui concerne
le forage du gaz en mer méditerranée
donc cette condition qui est émis par la
tap par la révolte de chiffres propose
un véritable problème et paralyse
actuellement la décision des vingt-sept
la difficulté elle est là pour l'instant
alors vous le disais un chiffre qui
s'opposent
aux sanctions européennes on le sait l
union européenne à la règle un peu du
consensus donc si nicosie reste campé
sur ses positions ça veut dire quoi que
la ville aurait ci ne saura jamais
sanctionnés ça voudrait dire ça
effectivement mais on peut penser que
dans toute négociation c'est toujours la
même chose dans les négociations ont
fait monter un peu les enchères jusqu'au
moment où le bon sens harry a débouché
sur un consensus je pense qu'on va
arriver à un consensus
mais il est vrai qu'il y à un acteur qui
s'est invité dans ce conflit entre la
russie et la biélorussie et qui est tout
simplement il ya cette race hyper dogan
qui tout simplement se dit c'est le bon
moment pour essayer de diviser un peu
plus l'union européenne face à un
problème qui la concerne est donc ça
c'est effectivement une espèce d'impasse
est le deuxième acteur extrêmement
important c'est vladimir poutine vous
disiez tout à l'heure
j'admire coûte in a fait valoir par son
porte parole qui n'est pas question
d'ingérences mais ce mot un gérant ci
peut être vue sous deux angles ne pas
s'ingérer dans les affaires d'autrui
c'est peut-être aussi ne pas forcément
vouloir aider autrui
donc ne pas forcément vouloir aider
loukachenko donc il faut le voir dans
les deux sens bien sûr moi je pense que
d'une part on arrivera peut-être à des
sanctions qui seront peut-être limité de
toute façon à seront limités à des
personnes elles ne toucheront pas
l'économie mais je pense que les jours
suivants ce qui me faudra suivre
c'est effectivement l'état des
manifestations successives qui auront
lieu à minsk
si ces manifestations continue à prendre
de l'ampleur
la question sera de à ce moment-là ce
savoir est ce que vladimir poutine
soutiendra quoi qu'il en soit son allié
loukachenko il est permis d'en douter
alors justement on va parler de moscou
moscou qui pour l'instant en tout cas
manifestement n'aide pas vraiment
loukachenko mais le soutien justement ce
soutien ce que cela peut ternir les
rapports entre bruxelles d'un côté et
moscou de l'autre je crois que les
contacts continuent entre moscou et les
27 entre josep borrell et puis remises
affaires étrangères russe pour essayer
d'éviter toute manoeuvre qui pourrait
commencez à créer un coin entre les
relations entre la russie et l'union
européenne qui sont très délicates et
donc tout le monde des deux côtés on
fera le nécessaire pour éviter une
solution qui aurait des conséquences
fâcheuses
mais ils ont que la stratégie de l'union
européenne elle éclaire l ai essayé
d'enfoncer un coin de plus en plus fort
entre la solide dans la solidarité entre
la russie et la biélorussie pour
progressivement essayer c'est pas gagné
essayez effectivement de faire en sorte
que à la limite cela divers poutine ne
soutiennent plus vraiment son d'allier
loukachenko françois poulet mathis merci
d'avoir été en direct avec moi je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste des institutions européennes
merci